Trascrizione: Giulia Scudella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Come Martin Luther King,
anche io ho un sogno
che purtroppo forse non realizzerò mai,
che è quello di volare
nello spazio extraterrestre.
Volare al di fuori della nostra atmosfera,
sopra le nubi,
là dove non ci sono
le luci della nostra città.
È un sogno ha da sempre affascinato
filosofi, poeti, musicisti.
Qui vedete un film del 1900
in cui Georges Méliès si immagina
di spedire verso la luna
tre ardimentosi astronauti.
Vedete che aveva anche delle belle veline
che con grande maestria
caricano il cannone
e indirizzano il proiettile verso la Luna.
Da allora sono passati tanti anni,
siamo invasi da tanti film
di fantascienza, più o meno belli,
che testimoniano
che questo sogno continua.
Questo sogno può essere realizzato
al giorno d'oggi da pochi fortunati
a bordo della stazione spaziale,
ma diventa sempre più concreto.
Compagnie e agenzie programmano
voli sub-orbitali,
hanno già venduto migliaia di biglietti
e quindi io penso che tra pochi anni
ci sarà qualcuno di noi
che potrà andare a vedere
la bellissima Italia dallo spazio
e che potrà letteralmente entrare
in un'aurora boreale
e poi più avanti, verso la Luna.
Non è un problema facile,
non ci sono solo attrattive,
ci sono anche dei pericoli
di cui dobbiamo essere coscienti
per affrontarli e superarli.
Ad esempio,
fra questi pericoli c'è il Sole.
Lo stesso Sole che produce
le bellissime aurore boreali,
emette anche delle vere e proprie
tempeste elettromagnetiche.
Sono particelle cariche, molto energetiche
che rischiano di danneggiare
le nostre attrezzature, il nostro corpo
e che dobbiamo in qualche modo
cercare di vincere con adatte protezioni
sulla navicella e sulle nostre tute.
Oltre al sole, ci sono gli stessi razzi.
Razzi che vengono lanciati ormai
ad un ritmo impressionante
e che dissipano nella nostra atmosfera
un'enorme quantità di gas
che non c'era all'inizio.
Non solo gas,
rilasciano anche tanti detriti
il cui numero è progressivamente aumentato
in questi decenni,
rappresentano un pericolo
per le orbite più basse
ma rappresentano un pericolo
anche per le orbite più alte,
come quelle da cui trasmettono
i nostri satelliti di telecomunicazioni.
Qualche volta un satellite esplode
provocando altri detriti
magari causando anche dei problemi
di assicurazione e legali
di non facile soluzione.
Detriti dunque che noi dobbiamo
in qualche modo cercare di raccogliere,
in un'attività di veri e propri
"spazzini spaziali".
Vedete una soluzione: un ragnetto che
con la sua velenosissima puntura
rende innocuo un satellite
che si era perduto.
Oppure con lo stile di un reziario romano,
di un gladiatore che cattura
con la sua rete il satellite.
L'Europa è all'avanguardia
in questo settore.
C'è un progetto [conosciuto come]
"spazio pulito" o "spazio verde"
che complessivamente comprende
molti tecnici, molti scienziati,
ma anche piccole aziende
anche del nostro territorio.
[Il progetto] cerca di rendere
sempre più sicuro e attraente
andare nello spazio.
Dall'orbita vicino alla Terra
un giorno ci trasferiremo sulla Luna
per fare i turisti e telefonare a casa
ma anche per i più ardimentosi
scalare le montagne
alte il doppio di quelle terrestri,
quindi ci vogliono dei buoni alpinisti,
andare su quei picchi
verso i poli della Luna
dove non tramonta mai il sole
e per questo detti
"picchi della luce eterna".
Oppure penetrare in un crepaccio lunare
dove una cometa
miliardi di anni fa ha dissipato
una grande quantità di ghiaccio.
Ma possiamo fare anche di più,
possiamo pensare di andare
dalla faccia visibile della Luna,
sapete che vediamo solo una faccia
ma l'altra è completamente invisibile
e [scoprire] il fascino dell'ignoto.
Oppure potremmo andare
lì dove nessun altro uomo
ha mai messo piede.
Possiamo usare la Luna
anche per sfruttare
i suoi giacimenti minerari:
terre rare che appunto sulla terra
diventano appunto sempre più rare,
altre sostanze...
E qui naturalmente si pongono
anche tanti problemi legali:
di chi è quel particolare campo
sulla Luna?
Chi mi dà il permesso di scavare?
Se un meteorite danneggia
l'apparecchiatura, chi me la ripaga?
Possiamo anche pensare di più:
qui vedete un aeroporto lunare lasciatoci
da una gentile civiltà extraterrestre
da cui partire verso Marte.
E si preparano a questa esplorazione
dei ragazzi
qua vicino a noi, di Innsbruck e di Graz,
e forti della loro esperienza sulle Alpi,
hanno disegnato
delle tute particolarmente importanti
per scendere nelle Valles Marineris
che sono il Grand Canyon di Marte
oppure per andare nelle grotte di ghiaccio
verso i poli di Marte
dove ci saranno tante informazioni sul
passato del nostro sistema solare.
Anche in Italia abbiamo tante belle
attività che mi piace ricordare:
un gruppo di Roma ha appena vinto
una grande gara internazionale,
sono stati invitati dalla NASA
al lancio di un razzo verso Marte
perché avevano concepito e disegnato
una bellissima serra marziana
in cui fare crescere i vegetali,
ma anche fiori con cui ingentilire
un terreno che altrimenti è tanto arido.
E noi qui a Padova cosa abbiamo?
Abbiamo innanzitutto la grandissima
tradizione lasciataci da Galileo Galilei.
Vi leggo solo quello
che lui scrisse nel 1610:
"Io non ho dubbi che se potessi
vedere la Terra da lontano,
cioè dallo spazio,
vedrei le terre chiare e i mari scuri".
E questo come vediamo la Terra da Marte.
Notate la straordinaria aderenza
di quello che si immaginava Galileo
con quello che vediamo oggi.
Quindi oggi noi possiamo vedere
ciò che Galileo poteva solo immaginare
e possiamo anche renderci conto di come
sia fragile questo ambiente terrestre
e di come sia importante renderlo
sempre più adatto ai bisogni dell'uomo,
sempre più verde,
come ho detto nel titolo.
Qui a Padova stiamo facendo molto,
l'eccellenza di Galileo si è trasferita
nei nostri laboratori, si fa tanta ricerca
ma anche a livello più basso,
pre-universitario.
Qua vedete un gruppo
di ragazzi del [liceo] Fermi
che da due anni
vincono una gara internazionale
per come sono bravi a far navigare
degli oggetti nello spazio.
Ma non ci sono solo questi ragazzi,
ad esempio mi chiedo,
ma la grande tradizione
a cui si è accennato prima
enogastronomica padovana,
la grande tradizione
di accoglienza e di ospitalità,
si deve trasferire nello spazio.
Io immagino uno che inventi
una bottiglia di prosecco
che si possa aprire
anche in assenza di gravità,
senza disperdere tutto il liquido
nell'astronave o nell'albergo lunare.
Abbiamo anche dei ragazzi che
volontariamente
si occupano di istruire le scolaresche,
le portano a vedere il cielo ad Asiago
o nel planetario di Padova.
Quindi una serie di attività
che coinvolgono tantissimi di voi e di noi
e che quindi merita
di essere portata avanti.
E quando la notte scende
sul deserto di Atacama in Cile
e appaiono in cielo tante belle stelle
e le due nubi di Magellano,
è come se il grande esploratore portoghese
mi dicesse:
"Raccogliete la mia bandiera,
proseguite l'esplorazione".
E intanto che faccio questa
lunga veglia notturna da astronomo,
mi vengono in mente
le parole di Pirandello che dice:
"Fantasie? No, signori, realtà. Realtà".
Grazie.
(Applausi)